in university he spent two and a half
years at the medical school at New York
University he has been on leave for the
last 29 years from NYU and in the
meantime he has become chairman of ACF
industries chairman of the board of
Trans World Airlines both of which are
held by his his company he is the
largest shareholder in Texaco holding
17.3% of Texaco outstanding stock and
also the largest shareholder in US Steel
with something in excess of eleven
percent of its outstanding securities
The Wall Street Journal recently had a
short story about the somewhat unusual
relationship that mr. Icahn has
developed with David Roderick the
outgoing chairman of u.s. steel and in
that story noted that when mr. Roderick
who has gotten somewhat close to mr.
Icahn over the years said to him how do
I find a friend on Wall Street mr. Icahn
suggested you'd be better off buying a
dog with that in mind I'm happy to
introduce Carl Icahn
to you thank you
well thank you no I mean you told my
joke so I don't have any jokes to start
the thing off with here but I will thank
Rand for flying us we can certainly use
the business and we're gonna call on you
maybe we can get you exclusively Rand
said that he that his people had told
him that I had retired as a Raider and I
can only paraphrase Mark Twain and say
the news of my retirement is highly
exaggerated as you may find out in this
short what has nothing to do with I TNT
rant I I think I've been told I have to
make this brief and it's hard for me to
speak on the subject briefly so Norman
is gonna interrupt me and give me
two-minute warning and I'll just sum up
well what I will say is that I really
believe that I believe this very
strongly that our country has has great
problems I in fact it's interesting I
agree with Rand on several of the points
he's made well I agree that we're gonna
have a bad recession and I think it
might even be worse sooner or later we
are not producing in this country our
productivity has fallen far short of
what has happened in in Japan when we
ended the war we were the greatest
nation on earth there was no one close
to us today we have fast becoming a
second-rate power and very few people
will disagree with this we are now under
producing in Japan we have a tremendous
trade deficit inflation is about to
start again and the reason for this
really has to be pointed at today's
management's because we are not because
our corporations are not producing and
the question when we talk about the
takeover mania that exists and the
problems with the debt that we have we
only have to look at Japan's balance
sheets
Japan has a great deal more debt than we
have and part of the reason that we have
the debt today is really a manifestation
of the disease that affects us the the
great is a great deal of money dammed up
in pension funds today and that money
has to get a return it it cannot go into
equities
because equities today corporations
cannot give the pension funds the return
they need to pay the retiring war babies
that will start to retire they will
start to retire after the year 2005 2010
so what happens is that at corporations
that can't make the return for them the
the leverage leverage by it has
developed what happens is that groups
will go in borrow from the pension funds
they will act as conduits bar from the
pension funds and buy stocks in these
corporations so by the equities and
develop a big debt and then this can
this can be corrected this type of debt
structure could be corrected if we just
changed some of the rules and some of
the laws that I will go into later on
but but right now what we have is a
problem concerning the country in
general the economy in general when the
war babies start to retire we will not
be able to support them because our
pension funds will have a lot of paper
they will own a lot of paper that will
own a lot of debt they will own equities
and corporations that cannot produce and
why do we have this problem the question
is the the question is why can't we get
rid of the management's and corporations
that are not producing that are not
achieving the results that these assets
should be able to achieve today what is
developed in that country is what I call
a corporate culture and it really is a
very interesting thing that we almost
have what I consider to be a corporate
welfare state you have levels and levels
of vice presidents and corporations that
have built up bureaucracies over the
last 2025 years that really actually
produce nothing and when a new
management walks in and tries to make
these assets more productive you
suddenly see tremendous results I mean
I'm just can talk about my own two
experiences we went into ACF American
car and Foundry when I went in there we
took that company over back three four
years ago and when I went in there there
were a hundred and these are nice people
I mean there's nothing wrong with these
cooperate the corporate culture of
people but when we went in there in the
neo the company was making a million
dollars a year 173 people worked in the
New York office and I went in and I said
well let me understand what you guys do
now that I own this company we started
looking at what they did and I couldn't
figure out what he's hundred
seventy-three people taking a five
floors in New York City did you know I
saw him and they went from one one one
guy would make him a pay it you know
it's a leasing business highly
sophisticated to another to it I said it
seemed like you guys go around in a
circle and they look at me and they said
you just don't understand this mr. Icahn
it's a very highly complex business the
leasing business you just don't
understand it as I say hey look I'm not
that stupid I did well on the college
boards for God's sake just let me yeah
let me understand what the heck you do I
couldn't figure it out well finally I
did something I'll never do again I
brought in a consultant bring in a
consultant Harvard MBA types and they
will come in say don't worry mister I
can will explain what these fellows do
will tell you what they do and they went
through came back about six seven weeks
later big book like this I said come on
forget the book here's your quarter of a
million dollars now tell me what they do
all right give him a check
God looks at me says you've been
straight with me mister huh he says we
can't figure out what they do either all
right that's the true story true story
so I said okay and I gave them all their
golden parachutes I did everything
closed the New York office down today
ACF now we never it's really scary to
this day I still don't know what they
did
we never replaced them we kept seven
people to do the taxes and and to and
today we've gotten all our money we paid
down a lot of debt at ACF we've got all
our money out we put four hundred
million back into the rail car division
with them hiding the best fleet in the
world today the company today has a cash
flow ninety-six million the income is
forty five million and I think those
assets if I hadn't come along would
still be making no money now this is
what America needs what we have to do is
resuscitate our asset base and the only
way we can do that is make them
management's answerable we ask ourselves
at times why do we pay a premium for
control when someone goes and tries to
take over company
it's almost accepted well you have to
pay a premium of control ask yourself
what that means when you say we have to
pay it for premium for control that
means that the company if you can get
control of it meaning the radar in
quotes that company is worth a lot more
like so what
the management is really saying if we
let you take control and let you get rid
of us this company is worth much more
now what does that say about management
if you have to pay to get rid of them
will be not too darn good and and that
is is what is what occurs it in our
companies today what what goes on and
why we have the structure I believe it's
anti-darwinian I believe that you have
in corporate America by and large with a
number of exceptions you have what I
consider to be the survival of the un--
fittest what eventually what eventuates
in American corporations today is that
the guy who gets to the top by and large
and again there are many exceptions but
by and large as a guy gets to the top is
not the best in the brightest he's not
the guy that really is creative because
those guys tend to be a little abrasive
but what you have almost is a club in
corporate America and the fellow who
gets in there is the guy that used to be
the head of the fraternity in college
now is some good had a fraternity so I
mean I'm not here to pick on everybody
in any fraternity but he was the guy in
college who would be there to pat you on
the back and have a drink with you and
if you had a problem he'd always be
around he wasn't doing much schoolwork
but you liked the guy I mean you
wouldn't let him run the family company
you might not want to marry your sister
but he was a good guy okay and he goes
into corporate America and he's still a
good guy and everybody else likes him
you know and he's there and he keeps
working his way up and he makes no waves
and he doesn't bother anybody okay well
but as he moves up this is the guy that
keeps moving up and he's always there
for the board members he gets to know
the board members they wanted tickets to
a football game he'll get him for him
and as time goes on he moves up and up
and up the ladder and then maybe he gets
to be number two next to the head guy
and the one thing that these corporate
CEO guys have one thing they have in
common that I find
generally speaking and again their
exception the one thing the guy has he's
he has a survival instinct he's good
politically he knows how to survive
eventually he gets to the top he brings
in a number-two man right now he's never
made any waves and he'd be crazy to have
a number two minutes gonna make anyways
right now he's a survivor right so the
number two man he'd be crazy to have a
number two man there was any smarter
than he is so the number two man by
definition has to be a little worse than
he so by definition and
two men is going to come along and
eventually he gets to be number one so
if you follow the pattern sooner or
later all that company could be run by
idiots because they can't you can't have
anybody better than the other guy okay
and this is what's happening survival of
the unfinished it's anti-darwinian but
this is a sad commentary in American
business and that's what we're going
through you gotta get rid of me okay so
I can't say too much more I'm gonna just
get but I'm just going to say Manasseh
and I'm just gonna say one thing oh you
know nothing about management to do what
I did at ACF and again I'm not I'm not
employee myself I've said it's a sad
commentary
I don't know dancing about the airline
business we took TWA from losing walking
in there I knew nothing about it the
company's losing 200 million and even my
critics say we'll be back Rupp today and
today we're making we just had record
earnings of 300 million something has to
be done because if I can do it it really
and I'm telling you that I'm not that
great at management I'm telling you
there was something wrong and if we
don't do something in this country about
it we have problems of what can be done
is very simple we ought to pay us one
simple law and the law would just simply
stated the law would just simply stay
that if somebody wants to make a bid for
company and I sort of agree with Rand on
this that it shouldn't be with somebody
coming in and saying I promise to get
the money those be he should have his
financing lined up he should be able to
just like in England go in and say hey
look financing I have the money I have
I'm not using the assets of the company
to buy the company I'm coming in just
like in England I have an investment
banker with the money or I have the
money but if he wants to make that bid
and he has the money lined up then that
offer has to go to the shareholders as
you do in England now you can you know
make this much more sophisticated but if
we had that rule there'd be
answerability and if we had
answerability
we do a great deal to make corporate
America a productive machine again and
to save that country thank you
thank you very much Carl this may
constitute an insider tip and I'm not
sure
Mary McHugh from the SEC maybe or Gary
you can tell me if this constitutes
prompt disclosure but I I can tell you
the good news is that Carl tells me he
thinks that newspaper companies are
overpriced along with the growth in
mergers and acquisitions of the 1980s
and the the restructuring of American
corporations that we've witnessed we
have also seen a tremendous growth in
the actions that have been brought for
violations of our insider trading laws
for violations of our securities laws it
has been the very difficult job of the
Securities and Exchange Commission to to
try to make sure that we have a level
playing field for investors to try to
make sure that corporate America is in
compliance with the the laws that govern
the American corporation the final
member of our panel today is Gary Lynch
who is the director of enforcement for
the Securities and Exchange Commission
mr. Lynch is a graduate of Syracuse
University and has his law degree from
Duke and in 1984 received the
Commission's Distinguished Service Award
which is the highest award that is given
to two officials within the Commission
he will be talking to us today about the
the regulatory environment that has
accompanied the growth of mergers and
acquisitions and the the increased pace
of business in the 1980s thank you
it was clear when norm asked me to be on
this panel and I saw who the other
panelists would be that I was supposed
to take the centrist position and as
events turn out I'll do exactly that I
think Rand is is quite right in saying
that in the 1980s certainly by the mid
1980s there were events relating to
mergers and acquisitions were things
were running out of control and I had
some of the recent cases that we brought
to justice that and I would also agree
with Carl that shareholders should
control the destinies of their of their
respected companies and with that I
thought I would begin by describing how
the federal securities laws relate to
takeovers because I think there's a
general misperception that the SEC has
much more power and that are we have the
ability to be much more intrusive and
take over contests than we and we
actually have the principle underlying
the federal securities laws is that
people are entitled to be provided with
accurate information relating to an
investment decision that they have to
make and that once they're provided with
that information the government should
not try to step in and tell them what
they can or cannot buy or whether they
should tender in response to a takeover
or whether in fact they should vote for
the incumbent management of a company or
someone who's trying to to take over the
company now it's it's my view that this
theory of regulation has worked very
well since the securities laws the
federal securities laws came into being
in 1933 and it's also my view that it
was working well enough until 1968 when
the Williams Act came into being which
is the statute that regulates tender
offers that now is not the time to
abandon the SCC's traditional role and
take over contest I guess I'm going to
break with the rules of this of the
panel and in responding to an earlier
speaker we were told that we ought to
give statements and then use the
question and answer
period to differ with other speakers I
would disagree with with Rand on the
point that he made that things changed
in 1980 with respect to the SCC's view
of its role and takeover contests I
joined the SEC in 1976 in my view is
that the general reaction to takeover
contests and our view of what we would
do and takeover contests stayed pretty
much constant from 1976 and remains
fairly constant up to this point in time
and it's a role that's dictated to us by
the federal securities laws certainly
when we get involved in the takeover
contest we don't try to determine
whether or not the incumbent management
of the company could do a better job of
running the company or whether in fact
the the bidder is we prefer to call them
rather than Raiders would do a better
job if that person was successful and
taking over the company and I and I will
tell you candidly that I'm not certain
the SEC or any federal agency has the
ability to rate incumbent management's
or rate Raiders and what their likely
success will be with respect to the to
accompany the effect of the SE c--'s
neutral posture in these takeover
contests is that we assure that the
shareholders get information that the
bidder wishes to disseminate and we make
certain that the incumbent management
has an opportunity and time to put their
position on the table before the
shareholders have to make a decision as
to what they want to do with their stock
and in essence when a company becomes
the subject of a takeover attempt it is
very clear that at least at the current
time the shareholders of the company
will determine the destiny of that
company and that result is in my view
how it should be and certainly how it
should be under the federal securities
laws which have as their aim the
protection of investors I would I would
agree that it also generally means at
least in the current environment that if
a company becomes the subject of a
takeover attempt where there's a very
high premium
offered over its current market price
that it's very likely extremely likely
that eventually that companies either
going to be sold to the person who
initiates the takeover or that it's
going to be sold to a white knight who's
brought in at the instance of the
management of the company or the capital
structure of the company is going to be
changed in a fashion which will enables
the current shareholders of the company
to realize a substantial profit on their
equity positions and the long and short
of all of this very clearly at least at
the current time is that the equity
ownership in public companies is being
increasingly converted into debt as a
result of the shareholders decision that
they want to want to realize a profit
when they have an opportunity to realize
a profit on those shares that they've
held for for some period of time I will
tell you that I don't have a view as to
whether or not the takeover mania is out
of control and I guess that's an
appropriate position to have given that
the SEC supposed to be neutral in this
contest I do have a view that the
current structure of takeover regulation
under the federal securities laws is
basically the proper structure and
should not be altered and it's it's my
view that if Congress and the country
believes that there has to be brakes put
on takeover attempts or LBOs or
management buyouts or whatever these
breaks should not be applied through the
mechanism of the federal securities laws
but rather should be applied through
changes in the tax code or through the
restriction of credit credit by
federally insured institutions or some
other means that that I haven't thought
of I can hardly speak before a group of
newspaper editors about saying a few
words about a subject that's received a
lot of attention in recent years and
then I've had some roll in and it's got
the added benefit of being takeover
related and that's the some people have
referred to as the as the Wall Street
scandals while I've been extolling the
virtues of the federal securities laws
and their approach to regulating
takeovers it's also very clear that this
system that was set up by Congress and
that we administer cannot function as
designed when the statutes and rule
flaunted by the participants in the
contest and particularly by securities
professionals who disregard their
obligations to their clients and to
their customers and to the free
enterprise system in general during the
past several years we've exposed some of
the fraudulent schemes that did take
place relating to mergers and
acquisitions in the mid-80s and some of
the fraud artists who were involved in
in those schemes and that it seems clear
to me that given what we've learned for
the last couple of years that there were
some people in the mergers and
acquisitions business who decided for
whatever reason that the rules of the
game simply didn't apply to them but
it's it's my view that 1989 is we're
moving into 1990s that the events that
that we've exposed and the exposing of
those vents will have a very solitary
effect on a system that seems to me was
coming perilously close to going out of
control that's not to say that that
fraud is not going to occur in
connection with mergers and acquisitions
or anywhere in the stock markets they
certainly will and with our best of
intentions when the best of efforts
people are still going to try to defraud
other people and every type of business
and certainly in the in the securities
markets but I think the last couple of
years that we've come through have been
the start of a cleansing process
certainly we haven't seen the end of
that cleansing process and these
securities markets are going to be the
better for come 1990's thank you
thank you very much Gary and we
appreciate your presentation on the
regulatory perspective in perhaps if I
can just digress one second before
opening up for questions in trying to
assess the truly awesome job that the
Securities Exchange Commission has to do
as our government regulatory agency in
the area of mergers and acquisitions
just to give you some sense of scale the
Commission brought any major securities
fraud case last fall against Michael
Milken of Drexel Burnham & Company which
was followed up by an indictment a
couple weeks ago in which it was
revealed that mr. Milken's 1987 salary
was about 550 million dollars which is
more than three times the annual budget
of the SEC with that perhaps I could
open up the the to the floor for
questions
would you please identify yourself as a
member of a SME and indicate which
publication you represent yes sir yes
James
Birmingham post-herald in Birmingham
Alabama across the country for many
years the heads of corporations formed
the civic leadership sat on the boards
of the United Way the Chamber of
Commerce
when businessman wanted to do business
with their colleagues they they went
across Main Street to do so what impact
has the Pegman acquisition and merger
had on the quality of leadership in
communities ran perhaps you could begin
with that and Carl perhaps as a
follow-up maybe first of all
related to it I'd like to say that the
way that Carl Icahn described getting to
be a member of the corporate Club and
getting to the top sounded a lot harder
than the way I got there and a lot
harder than the way he got there but let
me say on the issue of United Way and
the Chamber of Commerce activities and
all these other things
I think they've pretty much gone on in
due course we have not had a significant
change in the number of American
corporations in the in the Fortune 200
if you will there have been some mergers
there have been some takeovers but it
hasn't been I don't think the kind of
thing that has affected the social
responsibility of corporations or
business with the possible exception
that these companies where a great deal
of debt has been taken on whether it's
because of LVO activity or share buyback
or something else there might not be as
much money left over for contributions
when you first have to make those
interest payments to the bank and I
think that is an area that's been
impacted to a degree but I couldn't
measure it Carl I will say this I mean
in the companies that I know this is
working but in the companies that I've
taken over as long as the corporation's
factories or the corporation's
facilities are in these areas we
continue to give the same amount whether
or not we're in those towns the same
amount that was given before - what -
whatever organizations exist there but I
will say something else when it keeps
coming up that you know what about the
the towns and what about the Chamber of
Commerce and what have you I know that's
an important factor
but a more important factor is that we
as a country remain productive and that
we as account as a country are able to
use a productive machinery to compete
and if we cannot do that it won't really
matter about about anything else about
these aspects that we're talking about
someone who comes and buys these
companies if somebody does buy I mean I
think that's what you're referring to
you know someone comes in and buys a
company and he's in New York he's in
he's an outside of these areas and he's
not as intimate with the town that you
know that that company's running that
he's gonna forget it well generally I
don't think that would happen but but
the real question you have to ask
yourself really is what is the function
of a corporation and and if someone
bought common stock in a corporation and
that guy for instant lives of oil in
Washington and the corporation's
factories are outside of Portland
Washington's if the factory is in
Tennessee of the factory somewhere else
does that person really care if the
company isn't doing well does he really
care about that that corporation giving
money to the Chamber of Commerce in a
town in Tennessee or at an Internet I
mean what is the function that the real
question is that the company must be
profitable in a free enterprise system
that's the first thing and if it's not
profitable then that's the end of it and
I think that's really the question here
the question is how do we keep a
productive machinery working and how can
we compete in the future and if we can't
compete in the future and I don't think
we ought today we can't compete in the
future we have a major problem on that
and that's the thing that we have to
address yes senator Memphis I'm Larry
Beaupre from the Westchester Rockland
newspapers in White Plains New Yor
and my question is directed to mr. icon
the Eastern Airlines deal seems to be
unraveling and they have on the rat
I'm asking this question is a two-part
question what do you know is that the
internet' lines what have you heard
would you do and would you make another
run at the company if in fact the deal
with mr. Ueberroth is off and number two
is do you see the role of the union of
the unions in the Eastern deal as as
playing any future role in takeover
attempts of major companies well it's a
two-part question I think the question
really is when you say a run at the
company I think that I think it's more
apropos to say that that we've been
invited by the unions that number of
times in the last few weeks and the fact
that guy who got a call from him even
this morning to come in and make a bid
and I think that we've said that that we
are interested in doing that but we were
not going to compete with you burrow
because quite frankly we can't
understand it in our looking at the
mathematics of the situation we feel
that the common equity
well the equity owned by Texas air is
under water and we're certainly not
going to compete with a bit and we can't
understand a bid that pays 400 million
for where we think it's nothing so if we
were to get involved in our deal I mean
we would work with the unions and get
concessions from them and work with the
bondholders and tried to merge it with
TWA if indeed we paid a proposal I'm not
saying we would a hundred percent but we
would be interested in doing that but I
think the reason that Frank Lorenzo has
been so much against that talking to the
unions and you know I didn't realize I
as I said before I didn't realize I
needed his permission to talk to people
who call me on the phone but uh I guess
maybe he thinks we do although he's
withdrawing that lawsuit he sued us and
he was druid but I will say that as far
as Eastern is concerned we are
interested and would be interested in
working with the unions and making a
proposal but the reason Lorenzo was so
much against not talking to him I
believe is that he knows that we will
not pay
for the common equity of the company
because we don't think it's worth
anything so therefore we're a bit
confused perhaps astounded that the bid
is made and if that bid goes through and
that money is really there well we're
not gonna work
we wouldn't compete with that we have
time for one more question do it the
second part of that question had to do
with the future role of unions and in
such htech hell well I would say this
that I don't think the role of the union
is is so strong it's not a takeover here
I mean I mean the question of East and
there's no takeover I mean the unions
don't want to take the company over I
think that that I don't think the unions
have that strong upon needs takeovers I
think the fact that the unions are there
and strong make it difficult for these
companies to be prophets necessary and
therefore there's a change or a flux but
I don't think the unions are really part
of a takeover attempt in any way that
I've seen yes one more question please
inquired and I wanted to ask mr. Icahn
the key to your argument was that the
merger activity was going to improve the
competitiveness of American industry and
its productivity and yet after an
unprecedented period of such activity we
seem to lack a scintilla of evidence
that overall our economy is becoming
more productive where that overall the
companies that have been involved in
these activities are more efficient than
they are today and I'd also like to know
if mr. Aris cog had a particular
reaction to your contention in that
regard well I I just disagree with you
on that I mean I agree with you that
country is having great problems but not
because of the merger activity I think
if you look at the companies that have
been taken over and I can only quote
again TWA in ACF that I've been involved
in but if you could look at other
companies that the wind has been taking
over changing management and indeed you
know even in Texaco I note that Jim
Kinnear has said several times that the
fact that
that we were there he thinks help them
restructure the company he said that
publicly that that it woke him up I
think he used the quote there's nothing
the Centers of man's thoughts more
clearly than the fact that he knows he's
gonna be hung in a fortnight and he used
that a couple of times
voted I think Johnson and I and so
therefore even the fact that some of
this activity comes about what we need
is accountability and an stability from
a top management so we don't have it
today because really the value system is
wrong in these management's I mean we we
have management's they are more
interested in how many people report to
them how big the Gulf streams are you
know what clubs they were invited to to
go and make a speech at as opposed to
what the bottom line is anything maybe
you can't blame them because these
management's and these CEOs really
aren't held accountable for the most
part I think we you've seen takeovers
and I can name you other companies we've
seen to take over the assets of those
companies maybe in a different form in a
different company under a different name
have become much more productive and you
certainly can't blame their economy I
mean I think you're putting it backwards
see our economy has problems because 98%
of them haven't been taken over these
companies the 98 percent you can't blame
the two percent well you know there's
been more you know activity up for 1% to
2% what about the 98 percent that just
aren't taken over and aren't doing the
job you see so I think if you look at
where this takeovers of occurred
you've seen active again even where they
haven't occurred but they've been shaken
up you see a much stronger company again
I'll talk about Texaco but way you don't
have that and you don't have this answer
ability I think you see a horrible
situation today Thank You Karl
brand would you like to just take one
second to respond to that as well
in businesses is nonsense
it just isn't correct and it isn't true
to wipe up brush across the whole of
piece of America an American business
not a new what it's done I think we got
a big problem
everybody wants our business to be long
term everyone talks about long term plan
for long-term R&D say the business
schools get your management long term
oriented don't worry about the quarter
because of the way our dividends are
taxed away at the market is pricing our
stocks
we're subject to the most short term
reader thinking in this country right
now that we could have no I've heard
about what this management is like Carl
told me before this meeting today and
talking with us
he bought a building up near his house
he moved TWA headquarters up there
he's got housing up there for employees
he lives up there he goes a few minutes
to work if I tried to do that at ITT
with a public corporation he'd castigate
me in the press if he were coming after
me and I wouldn't blame them but you can
do a lot of different things with a
completely private company than you can
with a public one and I think a lot of
things you have to do with the public
company are perfectly correct and right
and they ought to be that way and I
basically would say that for American
management across America that it's well
intended its ethical it's real it's
working hard it's got some roadblocks
and hopefully in the Bush administration
some of those roadblocks are going to be
removed and a little more stability is
going to be given to the marketplace to
the American people for all of our good
for the long range that everybody wants
to talk about but very few want to do
much about thank you thank you very much
to all of our panelists today and
and thanks to all of you in the audience
if nothing else I hope that our panel
today suggests that not all of the
passion and all of the drama takes place
on on television or in morning sessions
but also takes place in the boardrooms
at American business thank you